Welcome back everybody to another video.
Today we'll be checking out a cheap and
actually relatively modern card here
with the Intel Arc A310 and seeing how
it stacks up with some gaming. Releasing
back in April 27th, 2023 under the 6nm
Alchemist generation, this Sparkle card
has some okay specs on paper. We got our
GPU running at 1,000 MHz at base,
although we can see it boost well above
2,00 depending on the game. Our 4 GB of
GDDR6 VRAM is clocked at 1937 MHz, which
sounds good, but unfortunately is going
to be hampered by that poultry 64-bit
memory bus. For our video outs, we've
only got one HDMI port and two mini
display ports. So, for your multimonitor
needs, you're definitely going to be
needing some converter cables. For
rendering, we've got the main ones here,
DirectX12 Ultimate, Vulcan, and OpenGL.
And while we do have older renderer
support like DirectX9, it can be very
hit or miss. But Intel, to my knowledge,
has worked out just a few of those
kinks. pulling about 30 watts under full
load. This allows the card to fit within
a variety of budget builds, including
optiplexes. Although, I will say to not
use any build that does not support
rebar within the BIOS. That is a setting
that is crucial to using an Intel card
to its fullest potential. Officially,
this is limited to the AMD 3000 series
and 10th gen Intel CPUs and above.
Although, I'm sure there are talented
people creating workarounds even as we
speak. Another interesting tidbit is
that while it does require an x16 PCIe
slot, it only runs in by8 configuration.
Probably just a cost-saving measure,
honestly. Overall, this AR310 actually
seems pretty promising. It's cheap, sips
power, and has pretty all right specs
for an entry-level card. But to truly
see how it performs, we're just going to
have to check it out in the benchmarks.
Intel has had about 2 years to mature
its drivers. So, let's dive right in,
shall
we? Checking out the synthetic
performance of 3D Mark. We've actually
got some pretty promising results here.
Overall, a whopping 6816 for Fire Mark
means we should be handling 1080p
relatively well here. And while 2810 for
Time Spy isn't amazing, if we keep it to
those simpler games, we could possibly
get away with
1440p. Compared to some of the previous
cards we tested, it's actually
surprisingly close to the GTX 670 in
score. The main difference here is that
extra DX12 support, allowing the Ark
about a 1,000 point advantage. Overall,
that's not too bad, actually. It
certainly has some decent numbers for a
low profile card, at least on paper. But
we'll just have to see how this
translates into some actual gaming
metrics.
Starting off with something decently
lightweight here, Shimaggami Tensei 5
has a few hiccups, but overall is doing
pretty good. While we had to disable
effects like anti-aliasing and ambient
occlusion, we managed a solid 80 fps
average running at 1080p. The lows are a
little sporadic here at 35 and 4, which
points to our frame times being a bit
all over the place depending on where
you're looking. Despite this, however,
at the end of the day, it was a Nintendo
Switch game, so seeing it run as well as
it does in the A310 isn't really that
much of a surprise.
But I believe he may be a
surp Impact runs overall solidly on the
A310, although there are some hiccups
here and there. Running at 1080p medium
preset, we're hovering around that 60
fps mark as we traverse the Nazuma.
Although, as we can see with our lows of
18 and 14, we can definitely run into
some pretty nasty frame time
spikes. This is usually caused by heavy
special effects during battle and having
to load in areas, but otherwise, I
wouldn't say that exactly hinders you
that much. 1080p low is there if you
want a bit more stability, but medium
settings will provide you with a nice
mix of visual clarity and frame
rate. While Black Mesa remains
relatively easy to run, we can see some
of the shortcomings of the A310's
architecture. These cards are meant to
be run with modern renderers like 11,
12, and Vulcan. And while it does have
support for DirectX9, we can see that um
there's some issues with the
geometry. Thankfully, Black Mesa
recently released a new update at the
time of writing that seems to have fixed
this a bit, but only mostly. Running at
1080p low settings, we managed an all
right 82 FPS average with our given lows
of 39 and 34. Overall, that's not
terrible on paper, but as you may notice
by the footage, our frame times are all
over the place, and it doesn't matter
where we are. They will jump anywhere
from about 4 milliseconds to 35
milliseconds with honestly little
consistency. While the recording may
look smooth, playing it can definitely
feel sluggish. You can indeed play the
game using the newest available update,
but it's going to be a bit rough around
the edges.
Counterstrike 2 ran surprisingly pretty
well on this little card. While maybe
not at a hyper competitive level,
overall it did run very competently. At
1080p medium preset, we've got a pretty
good 116 FPS average with decent lows of
76 and 42.
Running through this Dust Two bot match,
it was overall a solid experience with
very little in the way of actual issues
besides the occasional drops to the low
hundreds depending on the area you are
looking at. Counterstrike 2 has always
been decently easy to run, but in terms
of esports titles, you can indeed be
given a pretty nice time on the A310.
While Fortnite isn't an exception to
that rule, it was actually a pretty
interesting case here, cuz it wasn't
just as simple as turning on performance
mode and you're good to go. Performance
mode was actually overall worse to play
with. As with 1080p set to 85%
resolution scale, while we did have a
very nice 116 FPS average, our lows of 8
and three are showing the real issue. We
had some horrible stutters while playing
Zero Build and they can pretty easily
throw you off your game if they happen
at the wrong moment. However, putting
our renderer to DirectX12 and setting
XCSS to ultra performance, while our
average did go down to 95, our lows are
so much better at 72 and 14. There are
still the occasional stutters here or
there, but they're not nearly as bad as
before. I'm not quite sure what the
issue is here. most likely drivers. But
overall, while Fortnite can be a little
weird, it's definitely playable. You're
just not going to get those hyper
competitive frame
rates. The Final Fantasy 14 may have
gone through a graphical update with
Dawn Trail, but that isn't going to stop
this little card from putting up a
pretty decent fight. the 1080p low with
FSR always enabled. We got a
surprisingly decent 77 FPS average with
okayish lows of 37 and 22. There wasn't
much trouble exploring the Realm Reborn
areas and exploring a couple dungeons.
The only main issue I really found was
the heavy use of special effects,
tanking our FPS to the 50s. So, as long
as you can tone those down a bit, you
can actually have a decent 1080p 60fps
experience with this game, which I say
is pretty admirable for such an
entry-level
card. Working for your corporate
overlords in Deep Rock Galactic is not a
terrible experience actually. 1080p
medium settings running in DirectX11, we
got ourselves a very good 146 FPS
average. Although the frame times could
be a little bit erratic, reflected in
our lows of 51 and 15. Despite that,
however, we didn't actually have much
issue mining up some Morite playing
solo. So, overall, if you wanted to play
this game while only consuming about 30
watts of power, go for it. You surely
will not be disappointed.
Die creep.
Repo was never exactly a hard game to
run, but it is nice to know you'll be
able to comfortably play with your
friends without much issue. 1080p medium
preset here nets us a very solid 115 FPS
average, while our lows can be a little
wonky at 43 and 5. The main problem
areas seem to be the shop and extraction
zones, which you can see around the low
90s at worse. But overall, this is
definitely great to see that even when
on a budget, you don't have to miss out
on paying your
taxes. Vintage Story isn't the hardest
game to run ever, but I will say I'm
kind of shocked at how well an Intel
card handled the game. In all honesty, I
was expecting to have to dip down into
the low presets for 60 fps, but that is
clearly not the case. 1080p medium
preset, we've got a whopping 140 FPS
average with very good lows of 68 and
45,
respectively. There were barely any dips
or stutters we could see, which does
give it a good leg up from the Radeon
cards that are known to have issues. The
high preset is doable, but it almost
halves our frame rate altogether. So,
medium is definitely recommended for
those who want a nice mixture of high
frame rate and good
visuals. As good as blocks could look
anyways. Now, I knew Minecraft was going
to run perfectly fine here. This is a
game that can run on basically any
hardware you can throw at it. So, I
changed gears here and decided to test
out some shaders. Running at 1080p, 12
chunk render distance with BSL shaders
set to a minimum preset. We managed an
almost 60fps average with lows of 40 and
31. It wasn't that bad to play, but the
frame rate could fluctuate pretty
randomly depending on where you were.
Language shaders enabled is doable, but
further tweaking may just be required if
you want that stable 60fps
experience. I didn't think this was
going to work exactly, but I did decide
to give Expedition 33 a try. 768p low
with XCSS set to balance mode. We just
barely screwed by with a 30 FPS average,
although dips were common. are lows of
1711 reflecting that. This low of a
resolution also exacerbated the blurred
edges around dialogue to the point where
you can kind of see where the bubble
stops. Actually, it's honestly
unintentionally
hilarious. Beyond the visual artifacts,
the main issue lies in the combat system
where using QTE is crucial. If your
frame rate is fluctuating, you're going
to have a hard time hitting them. While
the ARK A310 is giving us a genuine
effort here, you should really wait to
upgrade your GPU first.
Continuing our futile yet interesting
endeavors, Cyberpunk 2077 was actually a
surprise to be sure. Running at 1080p
low with XCSS set to performance, we've
actually got a pretty decent frame rate
here. 41 FPS with our averages with
stable lows of 27 and 24. Roaming around
Night City and engaging the police
chase, there was only really one minor
area we even dropped below 30 at all.
So, while the visual quality is more
akin to petroleum jelly and has some
rather nasty artifacting, you could
actually get away with playing this game
on the
A310.
Oblivion was certainly an experience,
but hey, a man can dream after all.
Running around the open fields of
Tamreel at 720p at the lowest settings
we could go, we actually got a
surprising 29 FPS average, although the
lows would on occasion get absolutely
obliterated, leaving us with one and
zero. Although I wouldn't say that's too
surprising as we have a full 2 GB less
VRAM than the recommended amount. Any
type of upscaling didn't really help us
either actually. That's how badly we're
bottlenecked here. Smaller areas such as
houses could actually see a decent frame
rate, sometimes bouncing up to 60, but
that's really it here. Would I say this
is playable? No, not really. But you
could force yourself through it if you
really wanted to. You'd probably be
better off with the original though,
even if it might have DirectX9 issues.
Overall, I think the Arc A310 is
honestly pretty impressive all things
considered. For its price point of being
a cheap entry-level card, it does its
job pretty well. One of the main
trade-offs, however, is trying to play
those older games, as that can still be
kind of hit or miss. And there's
certainly cheaper cards out there if you
just want some display outs.
Unfortunately, with an MSRP of about
$130, this puts it within spitting
distance of an A380s price. In which
case, you're probably better off buying
that card instead, unless you have a
major size or power constraint.
Lowprofile A380s are definitely a bit
chunkier than the
A310s, but if you can get the A310 on a
sale about
$110, it will sip power, deliver some
surprising performance, and we'll be
getting driver updates well into the
future. You won't be playing all the
latest and greatest games, but this card
is putting up a very solid fight. I
would like to thank you all for
watching. While I did enjoy this little
budget card, let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments. I've
got plenty more videos on the way, so be
sure to subscribe to stay tuned. Until
next time, I wish you all a good day.